i was thinking to myself like what other
actor could pull off this mustache i
couldn't think of anybody i couldn't
think of anybody at all that could wear
i pulled it off every day at the end of
the the shoot
uh
no i think you know it it definitely you
know i've had some makeups that i had i
had to work pretty hard to transcend you
know the grinch makeup
could have just looked like a big piece
of rubber but i worked real hard inside
there
around
you know doing all the things i had to
do to make it come to life
and uh and also project a soul that
comes through and the mustache to me was
a
was a
an extension and a manifestation of his
ego
you know and it was like a see-saw with
evil on one side and good on the other
and uh
definitely tilted to the evil side
do you have to warm up like what kind of
warm-up do you do for a performance like
this because you are
you're all like top to bottom all over
the place when you're doing dr robotnik
when you do an eggman is it like a
morning of stretching and yoga like what
do you do to get ready i do stretch out
a bit but uh you know i'm i i'm always
you people on the set are always
marveling about like geez it seems like
every scene you're like you're literally
bending yourself into a pretzel uh but i
feel like robotnik is a outward
manifestation of this
flamboyant
you know everyone look at me how look
how glorious i am you know every finger
means something it's got a it's got it's
the flourishes and the mind is is is
fully manifested in every bit of his
body so it's just a natural fit for me i
like the emotion to hit everywhere my
big toes are feeling it you know that's
awesome
um i was speaking of paul dana recently
i stopped the set man
that's what i do i stomp the set
uh i was speaking to paul dana wristling
when he was doing his press for the
batman you talked a lot about how much
he loved you growing up and loved your
riddler have you had a chance to see him
in the batman i have not had a chance to
see him yet but he's a tremendous actor
just an incredible actor he's done
unbelievable work you know uh that that
one scares me a bit so it's pretty dark
but it's uh but geez i know that
whatever he does is going to be super
compelling he's just an incredible actor
awesome hey so great talking to you
again congratulations on this film
great talking to you too i want to tell
people about my nfts too there's a site
coming up in april i'm going to be
putting up a landing site called magic
hour where i'm going to show
some of my art mixed with uh my
existential musings and my mental
conundrums
so uh
i think it'll be pretty interesting
awesome thanks man thank you all the
best take care